we are used to decisions made in Downing
Street at the heart of our political
system but where does power really lie
at the moment deliberately pre-empting
the Prime Minister's remarks on Sunday
lockdown rules were tweaked by the Welsh
First Minister to allow people to be
able to go outside to exercise more than
once a day to allow garden centres to
open I don't believe that you will see
anywhere in the United Kingdom anything
other than the most modest of immediate
changes broadly of the sort that I have
proposed making in Wales so it would
seem that from next week all of us are
able to go out more and buy compost
while all the time being told that these
changes are minimal he still wants
people to watch the Prime Minister on
Sunday direction into the future people
do need a sense of hope about how we
will be able to move out of the current
lock down and slowly and cautiously as
it seems to me back to the sort of lines
we were all able to lead before it began
actually for all the talk of national
unity the nations have done things
pretty differently going into this
pandemic but coming out is going to be
altogether more difficult with the
Treasury watching as the mountains of
debt rack up to pay for these schemes to
keep Britain's at home now a Treasury
isn't something that the governments in
Belfast or Cardiff or Edinburgh have to
worry about making it so much easier for
those administrations
to call for the current schemes to stay
in place Scotland will need treasury
support for some time to come that
support may not look exactly the same as
it looks there know in the future we
have to flex depending on the changes
that are made to respond to the virus
but we've been very clear that with the
follow scheme in particular we cannot
have a premature withdrawal of that and
we must absolutely avoid cliff edges to
this in Westminster ministers claimed
that they were not bothered by the
comments from devolved leaders I don't
think we need to get too worked up about
timing
of different announcements Scotland made
some comments obviously last week Wales
has today the Prime Minister will be
setting out his approach and that
roadmap and how we intend to evolve
these restrictions on Sunday there won't
be much celebrating on Monday at the
return of liberty and normality what
matters more will be Boris Johnson's
roadmap for the nation going into the
summer
Sam Cote Sky News